prime minister thank you very much for
inviting me into your your lair here the
number 10 kitchen very welcome Boris
Johnson repeatedly promised me an
interview at Downing Street and
eventually ran in to a fridge to hide
from me to avoid having to fulfill his
his pledge your fridge is over there can
you at least give me a guarantee in the
next
35 minutes you're not going to run into
that fridge I I can give you that
guarantee but though if you get hungry
halfway through we can read it for some
snacks
it's a hundred days today
two list trusses or ten lettuces we
worked out because the letters lasted 10
days which was longer than your
predecessor
was your first priority if you're on it
simply survival given the turmoil of
what had happened before
you know actually I I wasn't thinking
about politics when Liz resigned at all
I was uh I was with my kids having lunch
up up north at in t-side at TGI Fridays
and we were finishing off lunch and
about to head to take them bowling and I
had somewhat moved on after everything
that happened over the summer so my head
wasn't completely in that space if I'm
being completely honest and obviously
she resigned and
you don't have to think about what to do
and ultimately I strongly believe in
public service and felt out of a sense
of Duty more than anything else that I
should try and come and make a
difference given it was a pretty
challenging time had it crossed your
mind when you lost that leadership race
to just get out of politics because it's
a you know it's a brutal business you'd
had to go at running leadership it
hadn't worked had it gone through your
mind to just actually try something else
not not to leave politics and I'm very
devoted to my constituents at home in
North Yorkshire and Richmond
so I hadn't considered leaving politics
altogether but I had obviously assumed
that my career in Frontline politics had
come to an end we're talking four months
ago yeah no that's why I said
four months my Fridays with your kids
you're thinking well I'll never work in
a cabinet again yeah that's what that's
what I was assuming and now you're in
number 10. yeah we're in your flare
you're the boss you're the Prime
Minister it's a little bit yeah it was a
look it was not what I was expecting I
knew when I resigned when I resigned as
Chancellor I said at the time like that
was probably I knew that would be the
last I resigned thinking and believing
that would probably then be the last
senior job I had in politics that's what
I thought I was doing and not to leave
politics all together but as you said I
didn't expect to be in in cabin or serve
in a position like this again and so
yeah it came the whole thing came as a
pretty big surprise but as I said the
country was in a difficult spot and you
think I mean and I thought I could make
a difference you said in in 2020 when
asked if you were after of a top job God
no definitely not seeing what the Prime
Minister has to deal with and then a
year later you run for that job
at a time in the economy is tanking the
party's cratering in the polls it was a
raging war in Europe the worst cost of
living crisis in a lifetime the remnants
of this terrible pandemic it's pretty
much the worst imaginable Hospital past
any incoming prime minister could ever
wish to receive which begs the question
what on Earth did you want to do this
for yeah thanks for reminding me first
of all a long list and look you're right
there's no point sugar coating it it's
not an easy situation and
you know I I also you know I do ask
myself the same question on uh on
occasion I you know I guess that's what
I said before it's a i for me it's about
Duty and actually there's a concept in
Hinduism called Dharma which you know
roughly translates into duty and you
know it's that's how I was raised it was
about doing doing the things that were
expected of you and make trying to do
the right thing
and even though it was going to be a
nightmare job for all the reasons that
you outlined you know I felt that I
could make a difference and I was the
best person to make a difference at that
moment especially given the challenges
that people were facing and what they
were seeing with their mortgages and
that's that's ultimately why I put
myself forward to do it and knowing that
it would be difficult and challenging
but ultimately doing what I thought was
my duty in that situation because I
believe deeply in service and and
thought I could make a difference to the
country when I interviewed Tony Blair
when he was prime minister here at
Downing Street he had a singing fish on
the wall called Billy bash bass I think
it was uh that used to sing if you
pressed a button Don't Worry Be Happy
do you have anything like that and what
is your Mantra now I uh I have my wife
but she doesn't sing Don't Worry Be
Happy
um and I know and we do like Bob Marley
but
um no look what's the right Mantra right
now for the public so many people yeah
are suffering so many people are
worrying what is your message to them
it's have hope have hope because I can
make it better and I will make it better
and that's what I said that's what I'm
working day and night to do that's why I
put myself forward for this and that's
why at the beginning of the year I set
out for the country the five things I
wanted to do for them which are quite
straightforward in in one sense the
problem you have I've seen the five
pledges yeah discuss those there's a new
poll out today you gov times times radio
that says pretty much on almost every
metric the three quarters of the public
do not think you're delivering on any of
the things you're now pledging to fix
three quarters don't think you're going
to be prime minister after the next
election these are you know pretty heavy
stats against you you haven't got that
much time to turn this around you've got
about 500 days or so maximum can you do
it have you got enough time to implement
these changes and actually see change be
affected yes I I wholeheartedly believe
that and I'm giving absolutely
everything I've got and of course people
might not feel that today and for all
the reasons that you you set out earlier
the situation is tough but I want people
to have confidence that it will get
better so if you you know go through
those things I said half inflation yes I
believe by the end of the year we can
have inflation grow the economy yes I do
believe over the course of this year
we'll get the economy growing again
reduce debt we've already made some
difficult decisions to to ensure that
that happens but we've got to stick to
the path and then cutting waiting lists
I was just the hospital earlier this
week talking about our plans to bring
down waiting times in the NHS which I
know we can deliver on we're working
with the NHS to do that and stopping the
boats and tackling illegal migration
that's probably the trickiest of all of
them but again it's something that I
care very deeply about and and I by the
end of the year when openly we can come
back and do this again and you can give
me my report card on those five things I
I am confident that we will have
delivered on them in the country at that
point will be able to say hang on this
guy
said he was going to do these things and
he's done them and that's what I want to
be judged by because I think politicians
say lots of things and the country's
probably quite frankly sick and tired of
it right for what they want is someone
to just do the things that they say and
that's what I'm going to do political
words are cheap right I mean anyone can
sit as prime minister and say to me I'm
going to fix everything the proof will
be literally in the buddy right and I
will set you up on that I will come back
yeah because people want to see actual
delivery they do I believe that and
that's why you know actually I get you
talk about those five things and all
that polling other people say oh gosh
that's not ambitious enough at all and
where's the Grand Vision and all the
rest of it and what I'd say to them is
these are the things that matter most to
the country you have a Doctrine I mean
people are struggling to see what your
what is sunak is it what is the doctrine
you have for leadership of this country
well first of all it's about making sure
that people can feel proud of the UK
proud of our country and that they have
peace of mind that things are going to
be better for their children and
grandchildren now that's what I'm driven
to deliver and right now what does that
mean it means delivering on those five
things because that's how we're going to
do that that's how we're going to make
sure people do have peace of mind that
things will be better for their children
for their grandchildren that is how we
will make sure people feel proud of our
country and that's why those five things
are the most important things to focus
on how would you assess your first
hundred days
yeah I'm
well as you said I came in and it was a
challenging situation but I'm proud of
what we've achieved I'm proud and how do
you achieve if you if you look at some
of the things that we've done in that
relatively short space of time first and
most importantly is taking action to
stabilize the economy and you you
mentioned it earlier about the situation
that the country faced in the Autumn
last year and it was it was pretty Stark
right people were absolutely terrified
about what was going to happen to their
mortgages what was going on and we came
in I came in and we took pretty decisive
action in the Autumn statement last year
to put in place an economic plan that
brought borrowing into under control
calmed the markets down made sure that
the increase in interest rates is is
going to be far less than people had
feared and that's going to make an
enormous difference to millions of
people's lives